Stannis is a killer
the Lannisters are killers your father
was a killer your brother is a killer
your sons will be killers someday
no elders build by killers what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season eight
predictions video today I want to start
a new series of videos I have given a
ton of predictions for pretty much every
single character in this story
I have given my opinion on what will
happen in the final episodes but now I
want to talk about what could possibly
happen after the series is over what
would these characters be doing if the
story continued after the dust settles
with only six episodes left we may never
find out how all of the surviving
characters plan to live the rest of
their lives but I want to discuss some
of the possibilities and today I will
start with Arya Stark she is one of my
favorite characters and I am very
interested in finding out what she plans
on doing for the rest of her life
assuming she survives all the wars to
come when it comes to Arya Stark in her
hit list everyone always talks about how
she will kill the remaining people on
her list but I want to talk about
something a little different when Arya
no longer has any names on her list what
will she do then where would her story
go moving forward we know that her
character has been highly motivated by
vengeance
ever since Oreo was just a little girl
she has been driven by her enemies
she once revenge against everyone who
has ever done her or her loved ones
wrong in certain situations this
motivation may have even been keeping
her alive but now that her list is
dwindling down what will she do next
there are only two names remaining on
her list which are Cersei Lannister in
the melon and as of right now you have
to wonder if Arya Stowe intends on
finishing off her list herself we have
seen a slight change in aureus character
although they almost completely devolved
her character when it seemed like she
was going to kill her own sister but in
season seven we did see Arya change her
mind and decide to go home instead of
going to King's Landing to try and kill
the Queen Cersei Lannister
aurilla did have an opportunity to go to
King's Landing and we know she had a bag
of faces with her but when she found out
Jon took Winterfell back from the
Bolton's she did decide to go home and
be with her family Arya and Sansa nearly
killed each other but they did make up
at the end and now John is on his way
home - and I know Arya is going to be
very excited to see John when it comes
to the stark siblings I think no one has
a stronger bond than John and Arya do
they are truly brother and sister no
matter who John's parents really are but
the reunion will be short-lived because
the night king is coming and this will
leave little time for the Starks to sit
down and enjoy each other's company I
don't think we will be seeing Oriole Eve
anytime soon - go finish off her list
not with what's coming from the north I
think the first thing Arya will do is
play her part in this war that's to come
all of us already know Arya is an
absolute badass and now she has a
Valyrian steel dagger which is exactly
what's needed to kill the others John
will probably want to keep his family
members safe though I don't think John
will want Arya out there on the
battlefield but I don't think he's gonna
have much of a choice
I think Arya will refuse to sit on the
sidelines while everyone else is
fighting Plus John has already said he
needs every man woman and child out
there helping win this war I believe we
will CRE out there fighting alongside
John and his other men
and not only will Oriya help but I also
believe she will kill at least one white
Walker if not more depending on how many
are actually left she has a Valyrian
steel dagger for a reason and it will be
put to good use but assuming Oriya
survives this great war what would she
do next if Jaime Lannister ends up
killing Cersei in the Hound ends up
killing his brother that would leave
nothing else for Arya to do in terms of
her story the show will be ending soon
and we may never actually see what Arya
does next but I think it's fun to
imagine these things anyway after all
the wars are over and everyone on arias
hit list is dead I think there are a few
different options I could see for arias
story moving forward the first one I
want to talk about is what we saw when
Arya reunited what there direwolf
Nymeria I know some people believe we
will see Nymeria again but there is a
chance we may not and if that's the case
then arias story may end in a similar
fashion to how my marry has ended
Arya tried to get Nymeria
come with her but then she realized she
never would because that's not in her
nature now Nymeria decided to stay in
the wild with her pack and this could be
a hint at Arya's own future but there
are at least two different ways you can
look at this at the end of this story
arya may decide to stay with her own
pack she may decide to stay with her
family instead of running back out into
the wild or arya may decide to go back
into the woods herself arya may never
feel right at home in Winterfell and
after the fighting is done
Arya could leave once again and travel
the world
aurilla did already show interest in
seeing what's west of Westeros so
perhaps that's where she could decide to
go next at the beginning of the series
we did learn how Arya intended on living
her life she said she never wanted to
become a lady she said she didn't want
to ever settle down and have any kids of
her own and she very well may still feel
that way but maybe she doesn't
aurilla story-arc began with her feeling
this way but it doesn't necessarily mean
her story arc will end that way either
typically story arcs end differently
than how they started Arya has spent
most of her life on the run and having
to defend for herself she has seen a lot
of death at a very young age and she was
even responsible for some of those
people dying so when this story ends she
may finally see the light and decide she
is done with that life if her character
is going to ever evolve then she can't
keep living that kind of lifestyle but
is it already too late for Orion to
change her ways now can you teach an old
dog new tricks I would like to think
that you can and most of you that know
me know that I believe horrea may change
her tune once she sees Gendry again Arya
and Gansey had a very special bond but
that was ripped away from her when
Melisandre took Gendry away and as far
as Arya knows she thinks Gendry was
being taken away to die Arya has no idea
Gendry is still alive and when they meet
again in season 8 she is going to be
shocked I think it would be kind of
interesting if arias story ended on a
happier note I think she deserves to
take a break from all the running and
killing her story began with her not
a family but it may end with her
realizing that family is more important
than running off again to King's Landing
to finish her list and the same could
actually be said for Sansa her story
began with her wanting to be a lady and
ultimately becoming the queen but her
story may end with her wanting to be
alone Sansa has learned firsthand just
how ugly forced marriages can be and in
the end
Sansa may decide it would be best if she
stayed single I think that could be a
cool twist on both of these characters
if songs that ended up being the single
one and Arya was the one who settled
down and had a family I don't know how
likely that is to happen but in my heart
of hearts that is what I would like to
see but I think most of you already know
that keep in mind all of this is
assuming Arya survives this series which
is not a guarantee at this point most
people probably don't see Arya ever
settling down though
that doesn't seem to be in her character
and at the end of the series Arya may
leave Winterfell once again there is
another thing to remember when thinking
about Arya and her connection to our
direwolf Arya named her name area after
a warrior queen who is most known for
bringing 10,000 ships across the Narrow
Sea to the shores of Dorne with that in
mind do any of you believe Arya could
set sail from Westeros after the war is
over I would like to think there would
be some ships just lying around for her
to take assuming they all aren't
destroyed during the battles Arya could
take one of these ships if not more and
decide to finally see what is west of
Westeros and maybe she will take a
companion along with her if Aria and
Gendry do not reconnect there is always
a chance Arya and the Hound reconnect
that is another thing I would love to
see but I don't know how likely it would
be that those two would decide to travel
the world together that might seem kind
of weird but I won't rule anything out
Arya is a very hard character to predict
for I won't deny that her story can go
in a number of directions when you
consider how many characters she has
built relationships with I wouldn't even
be surprised if she saw Jagan agar again
I think anything is possible right now
so let me ask all of you this before I
end the video what do you see aureus
doing in the season 8 finale after the
wars are over and there is no one on her
list what will she do next
do you believe she will settle down in
Winterfell and possibly even settle down
with the significant other or do you
think she leaves Winterfell and possibly
even Westeros let me know what you think
about this and thank you so much for
stopping by to watch the video I really
appreciate that
and I also want to thank my patreon
supporters have a great day everyone I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]